The Joe Rogan Experience if Brian was
here he would be betting
we'd get him bet on something stupid
yeah how much uh does he owe you uh we
lost count man I mean not only these
days well you must be up like
considerably right for sure yeah I'll
take care of dogs
and but then recently he's trying to he
was trying to get me to take a fight and
then he even called my manager I was
like hey hey bud are you out of your
[__] mind yeah he was talking about
on the podcast so he is serious he is
serious about you
start off as a joke uh when Jorge came
on and where he's like well we went off
here if I'm like it's not happening dude
and we're just joking around I was like
I fight another comedian I'll fight Lucy
K or Tim Dillon like joking around
and he's like no he's like Derek who's a
free agent Brian's like Oh Derek Lewis
I'm like I'm not are you out of your
[__] bare Knuckles Derek will say any
[__] mind are you crazy then they
threw out another name like well I could
beat that guy tonight my shorts and then
uh afterwards the money they're throwing
around is insane dude I wouldn't do it
how's he getting so much money they have
big time funders but the money's stupid
I'll tell you I feel you're talking
multiple seven figures
I guess
for my ego I'm like damn it's cool you
think I'm worth that definitely not but
you know it's great you got you know
it's a compliment but but Brian's out of
his [__] mind I'm like you have any
idea I'd have to Halt everything I'm
doing yeah get in the camp for four
months just to get in that fight shape
and then it's not like I'm fighting UFC
which I'm used to which is 10 years ago
bro you're talking bare knuckle MMA and
they want to do in Denver where they
allow head stops against Derek Lewis
yeah are you out of your [__] oh wait a
minute this is bare knuckle MMA yes I
like that do they allow Soccer Kicks
I don't know I think so man if you could
head stomp a guy both of those come up
yeah both those come up a lot Soccer
Kicks head Stomps and if they go knees
to the head on the ground
that's a good Trifecta that's the
trifecta is like the biggest game
changer the biggest game changer uh head
butts is one two because when head butts
are legal the guard changes illegal this
is your guard go watch any old valid for
sure Overlook here
and you're like this protecting your
head that's the stance they all stuck
you're like always put your that's how
you fight so far was the master of that
remember then when they outlawed
headbutts [__] changed then you could
open up a little bit but when they
outlawed elbows to the back of the head
that changed everything because there
was a time where I'm like why even get
good at rear naked chokes as soon as
they get the back you see like henzo did
it I remember John Lewis as soon as you
get the back you throw three elbows they
everybody Taps you don't even need to
develop
um any kind of skilled to choke someone
out those elbows at the back of the head
once they once they took that [__] out
changed a lot but change like is that is
such a vulnerable place you got a guy
riding your back insane and he can he
can you don't even see him yeah he's
behind you yeah I think that's how the
Enzo Gracie uh spikers yes he got his
back and he just started dropping bows
on the back of his head and they
remember he stepped on his neck when he
stepped off yeah apparently the guy was
talking a lot of [__] and the guy kept
calling him in his hotel like all
throughout all hours of the night so he
wouldn't get any sleep yeah yeah
some fans I forget which fight it was
but they pulled the fire alarm I'm like
you're waking up my opponent too you
dumbass
he's in Toronto I think no
but Brian's out of his mind regardless
yeah he's like I don't know why he would
try to get you to do that unless he's
getting a piece of it yeah is he trying
to get a piece of that agent piece yeah
do you have a [__] secret
conversation with he might have without
me knowing good job we'll give you
twenty thousand dollars
[Music]